hi I'm Erik Bosse and the Captain Marvel
trailer gave us a mysterious a direction
to the latest newcomer to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I brought up more
questions and answers really what is
Carol Danvers doing in all these clips
and what order is she doing them all in
why is her suit green sometimes and when
does she get the classic red blue and
gold wine why is the story set the 90s a
decade when it was apparently okay to
strike a senior citizen in public after
going through this trailer dozens of
times I'm gonna reassemble what I
believe to be the timeline in chronology
of Carol Danvers origin and the
interesting theory of why the movie is
presenting everything to us so jumbled I
know there's a reason everything happens
for a reason as to spoiler warning in
case you'd rather just going to Captain
Marvel blind which is a totally
acceptable way to live loser okay let's
start with putting this all in
chronological order
among the many flashes back to Carol's
past are some shots of her as a girl
falling and getting back up at the beach
playing baseball pilot Ian Wood appears
to be some kind of glider those
obviously happened first
I don't think Carol is Benjamin Button
this is followed by Carol and basic
training for the Air Force following
from the ropes course and getting back
to her feet next would be Carol's time
as an actual Air Force pilot with her
bud Maria Rambo and brie Larson has do
some interesting words to describe her
character she's aggressive and brash
impulsive and hot-headed she's the first
one to rush into battle and she doesn't
always wait for orders I think they will
see this rogue spirit of hers lead her
to fly too high in the Earth's
stratosphere on a mission encountering a
Kree ship this could lead to some kind
of dogfight or maybe just a mix-up in
the TBD plot point that results in pilot
Carol getting infused with Kree powers
the Kree response to this accident I
believe is to abduct Carol bring her
back to the Kree planet of hala and
brainwashed her into this super soldier
for their elite military team the Star
Force Carol's memories of her time on
earth get wiped from her brain new
memories get implanted in her brain so
then when Carol joins the SEAL team
space going on tactical missions and
helping the Kree in their war against
the scroll because they're awesome these
guys clean up Paula yeah
but during this time random memories
start to leak into Carol's consciousness
the concert a slip-up Carol doodle-oo
wonders you've only punched a hundred
old lady Scrolls this month is
everything okay
she responds I keep having these
I see flashes I think I had a life here
but I can't tell if it's real meanwhile
I think there's gonna be some kind of
major shift to destabilize the Cree war
effort either a division in the ranks
from extremists like Ronan and carafe
whom we know will later break away from
the Kree completely leaving their status
at the start of the guardians of the
galaxy or perhaps some dark conspiracy
by the Kree to enact genocide upon their
race plot twist from operation galactic
storm comics actually go into this
theory and my full breakdown of the
trailer go watch it whatever this is
this DVD plot point or Carroll
questioning or past or maybe both cause
Carroll to go AWOL and return to Earth
which further triggers her memory
flashes and which she gets picked up a
blockbuster by shield to recognizes one
of the agents as a scroll infiltrator
exposing this whole Scrolls Secret
Invasion and chases the shapeshifter
throughout Los Angeles and during her
time in LA she possibly reencounter a
Rand is new partnership with shield
perhaps the young agent suggests she
rebrand herself with the colors that
evoke his favorite superhuman from
shield history Captain Steve Rogers
so she dons this new more patriotic
version of her Kree armor as she helps
shield rid itself of its outside
interference and protect the earth as a
whole from becoming collateral damage in
this intergalactic war okay now that is
just my theoretical reordering of the
chronology of what we see in the trailer
but I don't think that that's the order
that these events will be presented in
the movie
according to reports Captain Marvel will
open with Carol Danvers already having
her powers so instead I expect the
opening of Captain Marvel to be an
action sequence with Carol in the middle
battle with the Star Force I mean a
better way to open a movie then but no
yeah but I think something that's matter
will trigger Carol to remember her past
causing memories to flash in and out of
her mind creating this sort of
bewildering amnesia now sure trailers
for every high interest property tend to
present things out of order that keep us
guessing about the story but I really
don't think this Captain Marvel trailer
was thrown together randomly or just to
look cool a lot of this imagery looks to
be edited deliberately syncing up
parallel moments in Carol's life in
which she stumbled and in which she got
back up to her feet and recharged so
they each look like one fluid motion so
here's my theory
I think the first half of this movie
will present a Carol Danvers as an
intergalactic super soldier whose
consciousness becomes unstuck in time
with fractured memories spilling into
her perception that in this
we cloud our judgment but she follows
these instincts and starts to reassemble
her memory which guide her back home and
then finally these memories snap into
place and she realizes that her past
stumbles and her past recharges are all
connected in one life narrative leading
her to recharge one final time to become
the hero she was always meant to be
unlocking her deeper powers to match the
power level of threats like go add a
nose a nose so if things go this way
Captain Marvel could set up the
present-day MCU in two ways one we'll
get a clearer picture of why shield is
set up the way it was why Nick Fury only
has one functioning eye and most
importantly why is ace in the hole the
most powerful Marvel superhero wasn't
called to help the Avengers in the
Battle of New York or an Ultron attacked
or when shield got compromised a second
time by Hydra Marvel needed to establish
this background in the 90s a decade
before Iron Man arrived on the scene
so that captain Marvel's arrival in
Avengers 4 doesn't feel like too much of
a random diss ex machina she's been
around but her relationship with fury
must be to fry for him to give her a
ring for that pager kind of like how
Tony Stark was reluctant to give cap a
ring on that outdated technology Fury
must be afraid to work with a quantity
that he can't control I think this
Captain Marvel story will be kind of
like the Civil War type of event that
led to their separation and secondly I
think Captain Marvel is unique
perception of time and I should say
possible connection to quantum energy
and you can learn more about that my
breakdown all this could bridge the
scientific elements that were set up an
ant-man in the wasp remember that movie
established that time vortexes exist in
the quantum realm look look I know I'm
giving you a lot to think about just
imagine that the way carol danvers
perceives her past memories as one
motion mushed together stark in cap
could also access similar quantum energy
to allow them to perceive parallel
experiences from their pasts as one
teachable moment that they need to learn
something from well comment down below
with your thoughts on this theory and
follow me on Twitter and Instagram @ e
hey boss also if you're really into
these Marvel deep cuts and you live in
the LA area come see my live comedy show
infinity fan I go into a lot of nerd
Theory rabbit holes and I mocked the
hell out of this process so you should
come and you can meet me and new rock
stars own Tommy deck told in person
might regret doing us Joe details and
ticket info are in the description below
and subscribe to new rock stars for all
kinds of deep
servile theories and explanations and
you know if you like what you see let us
know give us a hallo